here we are
we wouldn't now that it is we will split
up you to find belisle
and i will hunt his
god where do these refugees come from
i am not a god i am a shearer command as
it happens
she's heading toward arcanus but has
blocked
have you heard emperor
this gig leads to alcaz you'll need to
follow the long road over the canyon
bridge and through the casino
will pay for her wickedness
take heed traveller no then you must not
go
there are illusions out there mirages to
some
but i can see them for what they are the
covens
foul magic they will lead you to your
best
people couldn't kill me before they were
i would rather not discuss this these
overgrown insects wouldn't be notable
whatsoever
if not for their exceptionally poisonous
things
which alas killed my young apprentice
i thought he would be more careful when
i sent him to retrieve a sample from the
hive bus
his parents did not understand my
perspective
stay back they're in the locks
be careful they are very near to us no
one is here
the way is blocked
how did you know about the i am an
enchanter i am great well
i am also looking for someone
here let me clear the way for you
captain from behind protect the people
if not for you the lacunae would have
eaten well this day
are there more lacunae on the road to
alcohol even worse
let us head north to the howling plateau
the cult's magic seems to be emanating
impossible
there is another illusion here the
cultists try to hide their footsteps
but their spells are weak and easily
countered if we follow these prints we
can find their layers and halt the
rituals
our opponents may be strong but i will
not
need no time
okay
do
more fuel
uh
[Music]
no way
there should be another ritual
i need ready
[Music]
now
um
[Music]
need more time
[Music]
ritual is disrupted
bless you
what shall you do when magda is dead the
lords of hell
belial and azmodan plan to invade this
world
i will crush their forces and cleave
their skulls asunder
how curious you must be the one i was
meant to find here
i think it is time for you to know my
true tale
i am not from caldeum i learned these
spells
fifteen hundred years ago my sisters and
i pledged our service he trained us
and placed us in a magical space this is
an age of omens and prophecies
yours